تشويه واهمال تعاني منه التماثيل والنصب
التذكاريه في العراق والتي تعبر عن
الثقافه وتاريخ العراقيه العريق علماء
وشعراء وشهداء اصبحت نصبهم التذكاريه عرضه
للتخريب والتدمير والتشويه والعباث خلال
السنوات الماضيه الاساسيه في بغداد ورغمى
وجود قانون عراقي صريح يعاقب مرتكبيه مثل
هذه المخالفات بالسجن لانها مستمره دون
راضع حقيقي وسط غياب الاهتمام لتبقى
البناء العراقيه التراثيه عرضه للتضرر
الذي يمحي اثرها ويجعلها غير مؤهله لتمثل
البلاد وتظهره بشكل الحضري الذي يجب ان
تكون عليه المزيد مع زينب المشاط من بغداد
شواهدوا تذكاريه كثيره ازيلت بعد عام 2003
وبنا تراثيه فقدت هويتها البصريه بسبب
عمليات تاهيل وترميم لكن الحكايه لم تنتهي
هنا في بغداد تشوه كل يوم النصب التذكاريه
والفنيه تعالوا معي قليلا نعوذ بالزمان
لنعرفه كيف حصل ذلك
[موسيقى]
هذا المبنى كان لمتصرفيه لواء بغداد عمره
تسعه عقود تقريبا يقع في محلات حسن باشا
الى جانب الرصافه من العاصمه تعرض للهدم
والتخريب والحرق في عام 2003 وبقي على ما
هو عليه الى الان
[موسيقى]
للشاعر العباسيه ابو نواس تمثال يطل على
نهر دجله ويتصدر شارعا سمي باسمه انه واحد
من روائع النحات العراقي اسماعيل فتاح
التركي كتب على قاعده التمثال ابياتهم من
شعره لكنها ازيلت بعمليه تخريبيه في عام
2015 ثم بترت اصابع التمثال في عام 2018
[موسيقى]
وا يا حيره تمنيت
وفي عام 20022 يتعرضوا تمثال كهرمانه
الشهير الى حادث سير اسفر عن مقتل ثلاثه
من الاربعين لصا المتواجدين داخل هذه
الجرار الامر الذي اثار سخريه على مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي
[موسيقى]
مثال المسمى بنصب انقاذ الثقافه وهو
للنحات العراقي محمد غني حكمت فينتهك كل
يوم تقريبا
التي كتبها حكمته التي تقول هنا بدات
الكتابه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
تفرض الماده
477 من قانون العقوبات العراقيه عقوبه
الحبسي لكل من خرب او اتلف نصبا او شاهدا
في ساحه عامه كما تعمل الجهات المعنيه على
معالجه هذا التخريب بشكل دائم لكن التشويه
مستمر للعاصمه بطرق وذراعه مختلفه زينب
المشهد صباح العربيه بغداد
[موسيقى]
في امانه بغداد عادل العبداوي سيد عادل
اهلا بكم معنا في صباح العربيه باعتقادكم
كخبير في هذا الشان وبيحسب المعلومات
المتوفره لديكم كم نص بتذكاري في العراق
تعرض حتى اليوم للازاله بعد 2003
اول مره صباح الخير وانا مسرور جدا لانه
راح اتحدث في صباح العربيه
واشكركم والاختياركم لي اتحدث عن هذا
الموضوع المهم
الذي حقيقه يسير في النفس الاسى والاسى
والالم
لما وصلت اليه
الحال عند البعض
يعني الحال عند البعض من العابسين من
الجهل من الناس الذين لا يفهمون ولا
يفقهون ماذا تمثله هذه الرموز وهذه
التماثيل وهذه النصب التذكاريه يعني نعم
هذا مؤلم يعني حقيقه ولكن ان شاء الله
نعمل يعني
هؤلاء العابسين انما يقومون به مرفوض
اجتماعيا ومرفوض عشائريه ومرفوض قانونيه
[موسيقى]
رسم تخريب تشويه ممتلكات واثار يعني تعود
لالام السنين لماذا
تمام تمام
اول مره يعني اييه هو اكو ناس عابثين
وكناز جهل اكو ناس مدفوعين باذن الله
معينه يعني يعني هكذا بس هم دول عددهم بوش
كبير يعني يعني قلائل يعني مثلا تمثال
الشاعر ابي نواس اللي هو وسط الكورنيش هذه
الحديقه الجميله الغناء ما يعني صحيح هو
القانوني عاقب عندما يمارس هكذا الشخص
ولكن هذا يمارسها في وقت يعني لو باللي لو
مثلا في اوقات مثلا بعد الدوام الرسمي
وبعدين ما ممكن الحكومه يعني امانه بغداد
هي المعنيه عن التماثيل ما ممكن تخلي على
كل تمثال على كل نصب تخلي حارس توت تخلي
الشرطي صعب هذا يعني هاي عمليتها عمليه
قاسي يعني واحد مجتمعي
معي وطني ايضا حتى وعي وطني لانه ولا رموز
هم نعم
نعم هذا مرفوض اجتماعيه نعم طيب في مقابل
التخريب هناك
اعاده التاهيل واعاده الترمير لماذا
محاولات اعاده ترميم يا استاذ عادل لهذه
البنت تراثيه وهذه النص التذكاريه نلاحظ
انها تفقد هويتها البصريه
لا همم يعني اخلي اصحح المعلومه رغم هذه
الحمله العبثيه اللي تتعرض لها بعض مو كل
يعني بعض النصب التذكاريه احيانا ايضا هم
على طول الخط هناك هم عاليه لدى الحكومه
وتحديدا امانه العاصمه امانه بغداد يعني
تابع هذا الموضوع يعني باستمرار وتقوم
بترميم هذه
الاعمال الاعمال السيئه والعباسيه يعني
مثلا تمثال ابو نواس هو هو الهدف قص-
اصابع وانما الهدف همم يعني ايقاع الكاس
الذي يحمله هو
التمثال يحمي الكاس اعتبار همم شاعر هو
يتغنى بالخمره ويتغنى بالكذب يعني هذا
هكذا القانون ولكن همم يعني تقوم الامانه
راسين بتصليح همم التخريب
جاء يعني تمثال اخر تعرض للتخريب في مدخل
مدينه الكاظميه وهو لشاعر العرب الكبير
المرحوم عبد المحسن الكاظمي يعني هذا رجل
معروف بالتاريخ ومعروف نعم هذا هذا وين
يتعرض للتخريب مال يعني التخريب تخريب
طريف بس مزعج هو يحمل العصا بيده نعم
ياتون هذا هؤلاء تماثيل غير مرتبطه بنت
سياسيه يعني تماثيل تمثيل ثقافه وحضاره
لا هو عموما انا اعتبره عبس يعني مثلا يجي
السارق يسرق الحصه العسل الذي يتود عليها
هذا الشاعر الكبير والرائد واللي عمره
كبير هو
يعني تيجي الامانه تعيد الحصه يعني ما
يقارب 20 مره سرقت العصا ورجعت العصا
وسرقت العصا ورجعت يعني
هل في تقصير من قبل الحكومه العراقيه
بالتالي
مو انا قلت لك يعني هل امانه بغداد او
الحكومه العراقيه تضع يعني في جانب اي
تمثال شرطي يعني مو صحيح مو يعني هذا مو
يعني مو حل يعني هذا مو حلو يعني
هل هو المواطن ان يكون يشعر اهميه هذه
النصب ويكون هو الحارس وليس الشرطه الحارس
بالتاكيد يعني هكذا انا ارى الامور يعني
يجب ضبط البوصله يعني يجب ضبط البوصله
والوعي الثقافي قبل الضبط الامني بكل
الاحوال
الثقافي والوعي الوطني
والمواطن ان يكون عنده احساس عالي هاي
المنشات هي الي وليس للحكومه يعني هو يعني
من الجول ابو نواس من نقول نصب الحريه من
نقول نصب كهرمانه والاربعين حرامي من هذه
يعني علما
يحلل ويجمل المدينه بغداد يعني هو يعني
هذا المنظور الجمال والمنظور ال- ال- يعني
النظيف يعني هذا هو من صالح من صالح جمال
بغداد من صالح النظافه بغداد واحنا يعني
المفروض نكون حريصين على بلدنا وعلى
مدينتنا وعلى عاصمتنا بغداد اللي هي صاحبه
الارث والتاريخ الحضاري الطويل يعني هذا
يتنافى نعم نعم يتنافى هذا يعني يعني عمل
مرفوض وغير وغير يعني ممزوج ممدود شكرا
جزيلا لك